hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
interesting game to share with you that
was played on chess.com December 6th a
three Blitz game between Magnus Carlson
on the white end and Daniel nardit this
was Carlson's last opponent on his path
to Breaking nakamura's Blitz record they
played a group of six games this is the
one I found most interesting and
instructive the blitz record was 3336
Carlson is now at the top with a 3340
Blitz rating so really cool to see the
competition between these two each you
can be sure is well aware of these
records and trying to one up each other
so in the coming weeks months will
Nakamura oneup Carlson we'll have to see
some World Chess Championship prep for
this game a serious opening to be sure R
Lopez
now one of the things I found
instructive with this game is this piece
right here watch how this one minor
piece when posted on rank six dominates
not just one but two major
pieces let's get some standard moves in
here once white secures E4 there is a
threat to win a
pawn Black's there in time kicks the
Bishop back D6 prep work for the central
push new square for the bishop castles
security for the Knight prior to
D4 choran variation Bishop is preserved
C Pawn contributes this is one of the
points behind the churan get the C Pawn
playing in comes
D4 Knight D7 signals the carries
variation space now for Carlson on the
queen side Bishop
F6 Knight B to
D2 and in the game we now have G6 this
is one of the most popular moves in this
position in the computer's eyes what's
considered best is Knight B6 for what
reason or reasons well a knight on B6
factors in two Pawn advances one of them
being B4 black now in a position to
consider Knight C4 has support for that
jump and the other note is that it has
an eye this Knight on B6 has an eye on
A4 so this
thematic Pawn Advance A4 Rook Pawn
attacking a knight Pawn to activate a
rook uh it's not as uh effective or I
should say uh if you do play A4 here
there's now a cost and that cost would
be the light Square
Bishop all right in this game it's G6
right around the corner for black Bishop
G7 and
F5 we continue now with B4 and in the
game the Knight goes back to B7 if the
Knight tries to go forward here this is
not good because white can take this
Pawn is especially vulnerable probably
an overextended Pawn likely to fall but
on top of that a big Square is given up
to white with this capture A4 the bishop
is now able to snake into the weakest
Square in Black's Camp
C6 in this game it's Knight B7 in comes
A4 CB CB and now B takes a is played so
you may be wondering why is black
welcoming this bishop into the weakest
Square C6
what if black doesn't take on A4 here
let's say The Rook goes to B8 preparing
to meet this capture with the recapture
The Rook is no longer in trouble if this
Ram structure is present how does this
Fen kod Knight
contribute how do you undermine the B
Pawn this is Black's idea in the game
he's well aware that this bishop is
being activated
his idea is to now challenge the B Pawn
so that these two knights finally have
access to
C5 in comes Bishop
C6 two things happening with that move
there's two pins one move two pins Here
pawn and Knight are now pinned to The
Rook from here Rook B8 and now the
bishop with B5 is officially super glued
into this C6 Square this is already a
decisive Advantage for white very
accurate game by Carlson
here the problem here one of the
problems for black is the bishop is
annoying and if if you try to get rid of
the bishop you're going to have to deal
with an annoying Pawn maybe taking it
towards the center or away from the
center acquiring connected past Pawns so
however you slice it a fantastic
position uh for white here a bishop or
Pawn on C6 is a great Thorn In Black
side I said earlier that the bishop
dominates uh two major pieces uh we're
going to see that much more clearly as
the position simplifies but you may say
the bishop on C6 dominates the whole
board it's that good of a
piece from here we continue with Knight
B6
Bishop
A3 has an eye on a base
Point A4 Queen C2 Bishop E7 and Knight
C4 uh black is only playing on three
ranks really this is the furthest
Advanced pawn and even that point is
being challenged we get that Knight
exchange and uh some context here with
this three-minute game uh black spent
about 25 seconds on this next move he
played Queen B6 and Carlson's reply came
in about a second he had already
anticipated that this would be a move
and that the bishop on E7 would be
unprotected Inc comes Knight E7 if you
take you lose the bishop part of nitz's
calculation I imagine was to meet this
move he saw it was coming and his idea
was this counter punch Carlson saw that
one because his reply was nearly instant
he drops right back to F3 he's prepared
in this position to part ways with a
rook why well this is a super valuable
dark Square Bishop you might want to
think about that fing ketto Bishop as a
fourpoint bishop now there are these
ideas to do something on the dark
squares line the queen and Bishop up go
for mate completely winning position
here for white there is a uh uh followup
here with Knight C5 we can simplify and
we have now no Queens on board and look
at this piece this is where it becomes
Crystal Clear of just how amazing this
bishop is we have these files for the
Rooks but how do you get there with this
monster on C6 completely dominant
position and with this last Pawn capture
there is now a second past Pawn for
white the D Pawn is ready to go from
here Rook takes a
Bishop
B7 Knight
E5 possible Fork here Rook A8 normally
you'll want to uh duck The Rook exchange
when you're behind the exchange here
keep a rook on board help out with the
minor pieces but uh White is in such a
great position here you could actually
simplify this position further he
exchanges Rooks and gets the king
rolling
there's a clear plan to bring the king
all the way up here take a pawn and
start pushing there's nothing that black
can do he tries F5 Knight D7 targets The
Rook rook d8 and now cool move here
Knight B6 he's saying go ahead take me
I'm going to be able to recapture with
either pawn and then there's no stopping
my C Pawn so nardit comes up with
something clever here Bishop B7 his plan
to meet the capture with a skewer he
gets the piece back but white preserves
that monster light Square Bishop it's
once more glued to the G or excuse me
the C6 square and from here we now have
a third passed Pawn this one's over uh
what do you do here we get a couple more
moves in but three past pawns too many
the plan here here scoop up the pawn we
just get a couple King moves in but
there's just no activity for the rook
and white is completely winning this is
the point that black threw in the towel
if the game did continue we're taking
here and just
pushing uh all of our pawns there's
really not a way to go wrong here zero
activity for black zero counterplay for
black in this final
position what did you think of this one
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care
bye